you
[Applause]
it's nice keep eight hours away from
home to get mountains
you better get in all your calls and
texts because we are entering the dead
zone
[Music]
there's at least a house on right yeah
there's a house huh Wow
it's beautiful here
we're nerfing you want to live there
there's a power line going to it hi
so what are we doing mr. Stockman well
we have traveled to Tennessee to visit
this lovely cabin because every year we
do a Halloween special and I thought
it'd be fun this year and you agreed to
do cabin in the woods horror movies had
a cabin in the woods and I want to give
the viewers an all-inclusive experience
where they can basically experience our
entire trip and see what happens well
that are experiencing the whole trip
well I would hope even a little bit
private for us I would hope not
all right first cabin in the woods film
secret window
are you ready you stole my story I don't
believe I know you I know you mr. Rainey
that's what matters you stole my story
kind of an amazing coincidence the
story's being so much alike her death
will be a mystery Todd Downey said
the guy calls himself shooter maybe my
name not shooter welcome to our fourth
annual scary movie special my wife and I
every single year on Halloween we like
to do a scary movie special this is our
fourth year doing it and this year we
did something very special we went all
the way to a cabin in Tennessee to watch
films that feature cabins in the woods
because we're in a cabin in the woods
right now thank you once again for
joining me for another year honey I
appreciate it we've done two of these
before we are married and two of them
married that's true if you guys want to
watch any of our other specials they're
all linked in the description below this
is something really fun we like to do
because October is like the best month
ever it's so much fun the first film
we're going to be talking about is
secret window and we just watched it
secret window is a movie that's kind of
nostalgic for me it has narrative flaws
it has not the best characters it has a
clash of tone there's a lot of humor in
the film that doesn't always mix very
well with it's more suspenseful aspects
the ending maybe doesn't work very well
but I am compelled by it mostly I admire
the performances I admire Johnny Depp in
the movie a lot I think he's really good
he doesn't have the most interesting
character then I forget something you
brought him know I lost interest in this
film about 15 minutes in I was like this
is just so dragging and dull it wasn't
my type of film I could see where are
some people who like those type of
psychological thrillers would be really
into it
I just however could not get into it I
mean it's not terrible but it's not
something I'm gonna ever probably want
to watch again I can understand that
it's not a movie for everybody and like
I said it's by no means is a perfect
film I wouldn't even call it a great
film I hesitate to call it a good film
because it does have a lot of problems
with its story it's trying to tell a
story about a guy who is being accused
of plagiarism
he has writer's block he's going through
a divorce there's strange things going
on in his house that he can't quite
explain and there's also a lot of humor
that's thrown in it's written and
directed by David Koepp and he is a very
good writer but he has
our time adapting Stephen King's novella
into a fully compelling film here
because there's so much going on in this
story and he has a hard time really
harnessing it into a complete vision but
what I like about the movie is the
setting I'm a sucker for cabins I think
the woods are very intriguing I love
Johnny Depp I think it's one of his more
underrated roles because he tends to
play very eccentric and weird characters
and I like seeing him play sort of like
a normal guy even though eventually
spoilers if you've never seen see your
window is revealed that he isn't quite
normal at all not at least been tracked
like I said he's just had a compelling
character for 90% of the film so by the
time he does become an interesting
character you don't really have any
interest in him even though he's now an
interesting character so there's flow
issues there's dynamic issues there's
character problems I just it's one of
those ones it's kind of hard to get into
unless you're into psychological
thrillers then it might be something
you'd want to watch that's true it's not
like a straight forward film there is a
lot of like I said it jumps all over a
lot in regards to tone but it is type of
film that you watch differently the
second time if you don't know how it
ends and I like the fact that it's about
a writer trying to struggle with a
writer's block because anyone who's ever
tried to write something before
understands how that feels but like I
said and I think like you said it just
tries to do too many things at once and
tries to be too many things and I think
its first act as in its first 30 minutes
are very good and I like the ending as
well it's the middle portion of the film
for me that drags and he goes to a
police investigator
I admire it it's nostalgic for me I saw
it back in the day in theatres with my
friends and family and we all had a good
time but over the years it doesn't hold
up as well as when I was younger when I
first saw it man you're getting old
you're just systolic about everything
anymore yeah like you're almost 30 we've
hit this generation now where it's like
we look back and everything is now 20
years ago for us really yeah I was
thinking about that there they was like
I just saw a secret window it was like
10 years ago no that was back in 2004
that was actually 12 years ago so yeah
it's one of those things so are you
ready to dig into our bag
eight films we're going to be talking
about that feature cabins in the woods
and pick a new one let's see where is it
let's do it
Dog Soldiers isn't commonly viewed as a
cabin in the woods film but it does have
an entire last half that takes place
with soldiers held up in a cabin with
werewolves at the door this is a very
low-budget British film directed by Neil
Marshall who later went on to direct the
descent and has since done a lot of TV
he's a good horror director and he made
a really really badass werewolf movie
with an extremely low budget in fact
sometimes the budget is a hindrance
because they can't really cut to the
werewolves too much because you would
see the suits just don't really look all
that good but what's cool about Dog
Soldiers is the really hardened elements
with the squad of soldiers who are
facing off against these werewolves
because it's a very predator type feel
these are the most badass of badasses
they say things and you're like what do
you what does that even mean what does
that word mean is that like some what
does that mean I don't know what that
means you're just so much more badass
than I am the wife didn't get a chance
to see this one but I do think that at
some point you should check it out the
dog does not die in it so there is that
I don't like animals dying in films it's
just it's we're about the werewolves
like can you watch werewolves die
because because they're animals
technically while they're human animals
I guess maybe I don't know it falls into
that weird category they don't like see
the animals here one of the things about
Dog Soldiers is that it was shot on very
low budget 16 millimeter and so it
didn't transfer very well to the high
def era this is probably the best
looking blu-ray that's released of Dog
Soldiers the shout factory version the
one before this might as well have been
an upscale DVD if you want to check that
film out it is pretty hardcore it has a
lot of really good action sequences it
has a lot of intensity to it and some
good characters and the werewolf stuff
is fun as well and I think it's as good
of a low-budget werewolf movie as they
possibly could have made
what oh shit
[Music]
currently time is 3:07 a.m. something
keeps waking me and Sam up it's like a
scratching noise
all right so it's now morning I didn't
get a really good sleep something kept
waking me up and I kept looking for it
but I never found what was waking me up
I don't know we'll see how Chris lap
he's still sleeping I'm making breakfast
let's see how's breakfast doing and we
have the really cool pond
apparently it's stocked with fish so if
we wanted to go fishing we could
ah maybe Chris will wake up at some
point though
oh man that's lad anyway that's what I'm
doing today like I said this didn't
sleep very well when I try to get it on
nap um maybe nap yeah definitely going
to do a nap hopefully now he wakes me up
this time
[Music]
come on get in the bath every rap
okay hey huh
Regis outside no hon that wasn't me
maybe it was Bruce Campbell I could have
sworn I saw somebody outside can you
maybe go take a look
sure I'll look dark cabin at night the
wife is scared I am now on a mission
you know if John Turturro shows up with
a southern accent I'm gonna be pissed
there's the bathroom window
it's not even unlocked
you know there's a lot of places I'd
rather be than here so just gonna go ah
[Music]
hello
shit
you've got to be fucking kidding me well
is there anybody out there
yeah actually
what do you mean
because the old lady that lives over
there why would she be down here I don't
think they're renters are supposed to
see the universe look if the owners want
somebody to check on us just have them
let us know first it was creepy shit
we'll just watch the movie or going to
college okay
[Music]
smile your soul
Evil Dead - Dead by Dawn Evil Dead - the
classic directed by Sam Raimi the sequel
it's kind of a reboot slash remake it's
a weird thing that doesn't quite make
sense but it's Evil Dead 2 and in my
opinion it's the one to watch Evil Dead
2 is of course starring Bruce Campbell
as I said directed or written by Sam
Raimi these guys grew up making films
together they've been friends forever
and it shows in this movie because it
really does feel like a film that two
guys just kind of made together kind of
does it looks like a lot of the shorts
he made as a kid yes it does obviously
with much better with much better budget
yeah better technique better everything
better lighting and stuff it's not
little children exactly be adults and
there's girls in Evil Dead 2 yeah we
didn't have those when we were kids we
had no friends of the female nature I
got to say watching some of these movies
especially this one in an actual cabin
in the woods has really changed my
entire viewpoint of them it provides a
kind of different cool experience yeah
it bring this to life some of the more
edginess of it yes definitely freak
yourself out a little bit more when you
know there's absolutely nobody around
for miles yeah it's actually a very cool
experience to actually watch these
movies in a location very similar to
them this movie has incredible practical
effects especially for such a low budget
a lot of the effects are still very good
today mostly the practical stuff with
all the blood flying everywhere and the
creatures and the design yes yes has a
fountain of blood everywhere it's like I
don't think the human body holds that
much blood enough oh go away
hell no yeah it's it's obviously Fagin
and I think that's one of the things I
love about it so much is because you can
really feel that Sam Raimi and Bruce
Campbell have a love for very cheesy
horror effects and cheesy horror cliches
and they're just throwing everything at
the screen they're taking the rule book
and just throwing it out the door
they're saying a guy in a cabin and just
forcing him through 90 minutes of
and sanity he has a chainsaw for a hand
one of the best scenes in the movie the
epic cuts where it goes like shoot mmm
groovy it's so great it's classic it's
classic horror
I love evil good too I laughed this
whole way through I was like this is not
good but it's fine so legend says that
this movie wasn't gonna get made but
Stephen King was such a fan of the Evil
Dead that he called people around and
you know pulled some strings and helped
Sam Raimi get his budget together for
Evil Dead 2 so that's pretty cool yes I
would love for Stephen King to make a
few calls for me IV amazing can you do
that please
I'm a big fan of you
all right guys kicking off our next
review wrong turn by Rob Smith
thankfully we are not in West Virginia
sure and you know we were almost in West
Virginia
there was another cabin I was looking at
that was in West Virginia well thank God
we didn't go there cuz this movie would
give me some chills at this point do not
eat food before or during this movie ooh
probably you're not gonna want food
after it so don't make plans to eat
after this yeah I feel bad for like the
guy that went to this movie back in 2003
whenever it came out ordered hot dogs
and popcorn and candy and just stuff his
face and then like 20 minutes in was
like so this isn't a food movie I guess
the guys faces it alone we're not to
make your stump at a turn yeah good
makeup Stan Winston did a lot of
uncredited makeup work in this film
which is about some cannibalistic inbred
crazy people who live in the backwoods
of West Virginia in a cabin and some
unsuspecting young people who are very
attractive of course and lied to reveal
their mid drifts and have very sexy
looks in the middle of horrific danger
of course perfect quaffed hair the
entire time it's true you notice that
yeah and the girls white tank top stays
white pretty much the entire time so for
one little red blood stain did they I
only remember seeing them add fake sweat
know if they didn't cuz hot girls they
don't sweat really not just stare just
stays curly and the humidity in the
woods because any girls here is gonna
stay perfect in the middle of the woods
while they're sweating they stay Maxim
magazine level hot throughout the entire
film the guy was really attractive too
so they took like two really attractive
characters of course they've really only
wants to survive yeah yes mediocre
looking people of course we're the ones
to go you ugly is over there you just go
over there and die
black people have to be in the movie
right free ones would happen exactly the
one girl was kind of hot they were all
pretty good-looking people it's just
it's just like certain characters who
have maybe a little more
characterization than others they get to
have more screen time I guess and the
other people are just there to be killed
this is a okay film it's not great it's
not terrible I I find it to be a fairly
disposable horror film that you can
watch and just kind of throw away and
it's fun it's not like you watching are
like you know deeply offended by how
terrible it is it's just don't eat
anything is kind of like what we're
saying but as a horror film that's
mostly a conventional film that follows
a lot of cliches it's pretty good
that's just the horror genre sometimes
you get some really good ones and
sometimes you just get some middle
ground and then you get the bottom of
the barrel and then you hit the rock
bottom of the barrel that are so bad
they're really good there are like five
sequels to this there's there's a wrong
turn six that came out semi recently
it's just one of those movies that is
just it's it's open for whatever you
know it even has like a bit of a
open-ended thing where they set up for a
seat
that's the fridge is the fridge it's not
a weird person knocking hopefully I mean
that a woman couldn't be that good she
you know fuck that girl I don't know
what that was I these people made sure
was a girl that's true
jos ice maker I think hey great maybe
probably
I'm not going outside that always
happens in the horror films so we're
just gonna stay inside no no no
hopefully we don't hear any more of
those weird noises and seriously tell
tell the landlord or whoever owns this
to stop don't send people you know I
mean like why would they why would they
send people to check on us like some old
creepy lady to scare the shit out of us
[Music]
um hi I really don't think you're
supposed to be here
could you leave
yeah I'm just going back into bed I
didn't see that
did you look outside yeah I did didn't
she was steamy there I don't know why
she came up and tried to open it why
didn't you wake me up you didn't wake up
from her rattle in the door really
loudly like you're gonna wake up from me
poking you oh I'm sorry that's I don't
really know what to say actually
[Music]
I got you I got you okay I don't know if
we're gonna be able to get the purple
one time
you
what you doing oh yes baby
are you ready for pumpkin head was an
accident
[Music]
it's God from its cars now
all right guys pumpkin head I had never
actually seen pumpkin head until fairly
recently I saw for the first time like a
week ago and based on a lot of
recommendations it was directed by Stan
Winston who is primarily known for
creature effects and he's directed a few
things he directed the really long
Michael Jackson video ghosts it's like a
35 minute music video more unknown in
regards to Jackson's songs oh this movie
he actually did show a surprising
knowledge of filmmaking that I genuinely
didn't expect this movie had been on a
list of horror film classics that I've
tried to watch a number of times with my
friends but he's usually on the bottom
part of a list to be like by time you
made it to it you were like half asleep
so maybe he was on in the background and
I wasn't even paying attention yeah so
finally got to actually sit down and
watch it and actually for being made in
1988 held up really well surprisingly
yeah we had to call it about halfway
through that this was actually better
than the prequel trilogy in terms of
special effects that this was made in 88
strangely I came out the year of my
birth and the the creature effects are
surprisingly pretty good and a lot of
that's due to the fact that Stan
Winston's team is marvelous they've done
things with like you know Terminator 2
and great effects for a really long time
rest in peace mr. Winston but um with
this movie he knows when to show the
creature too much and when to not show
it too much right actually even when you
do see the creature it's very believable
as a creature it's like all very
practical looking and the makeups very
on point for this film definitely and I
know it's supposed to be a funny creepy
but you kind of get that where it's like
oh this is kind of disturbing yeah a lot
of its due the fact that the movie has
some balls it tells a rather tragic
story I mean something happens to this
guy a father who who's caring for a son
and this causes him to want to raise
this demon known as Pumpkinhead for
revenge and he has to go to this cabin
in the woods where this witch lives and
she says I'll do this for you but it's
going to take a price and he starts
witnessing through the eyes of
Pumpkinhead
this thing going around killing the
teenagers who were accidentally
responsible for this man's son's death
and so it's not like it's just a
throwaway teenage horror film it
actually has some balls - it's a little
tragic at times really tragic max
actually I was beginning of the film I'm
like oh no he said the Joker the kid are
gonna die I turned to Chris which one is
it because if it's a dog I'm Bailey
because I can't watch another dog die
the makeup on the which is also really
cool I mean that's one of the things
that I think is gonna be fairly timeless
with Pumpkinhead is the makeup work I
love the lighting of the movie - it's a
lot very orange there's always light
shining through like at the end with a
dilapidated church with the light coming
through and all the fog and everything
it's a well shot movie it's a very fun
1980s horror film that I think has kind
of been tossed under the rug for a lot
of people maybe revisit shout factory
has a pretty good blu-ray release of it
it's really good it's a really good
transfer compared to some of the ones
I've seen check it out sometime it's a
good cabin in the woods horror film I
think we both enjoyed it this was so far
the best of the lot oh nice I'm glad you
liked it well we have another one to
talk about very soon are you ready let's
do it let's do it you're missing the
point I wanna see a Spanish
well if we're going to do a special on
films that have cabins in the woods of
the horror themed genre how could we not
talk about the cabin in the woods and
movie that is is that you know I mean
this film was very much so a satirical
look at movies like Evil Dead really all
the horror films of the past like 30
years really and how they all kind of
can be correlated into one basic story
structure the one formula that makes
them all I remember when I first saw
this in 2012
I drove a couple hours away to Columbus
for like a special screening because the
director was going to be there Drew
Goddard and the lead actress Kristen
Connelly I got to meet them both it was
really cool when it progresses and gets
weirder and weirder and weirder it does
it just gets weird it blew me away you
can't really follow it until the end
where it's like oh okay
now I got it right and I'm intrigued by
this cover I didn't I've already seen it
by like where it's just the cabin its
particular yeah I didn't realize that
like it made all the little cubicle
things that are in the end one of the
better horror posters of recent years
stuff yeah
originally cabin in the woods was
actually shelved it was filmed in like
oh nine or something and was shelled for
like three years I forget why but it was
like before Chris Hemsworth was known
for Thor and they got to release it
a year after Thor and they were like oh
Thank You Thor now he's more famous from
when we filmed this so while we were
watching this I was like okay this is
going to follow the classic formula and
of course it does but it pokes fun at
that yeah formula and I love when they
do that because it's you can count on
exactly who's going to die in every
horror film right from the beginning and
it's kind of annoying because it's like
well that's predictable that's
predictable they're gonna die they're
gonna die they're gonna die that's the
person that's going to be alive or
partially live or dismembered but still
alive and you see their body being
dragged off screen used however there's
always that one person it's going to be
alive at the end mmm-hmm or the monster
is seen following them sure yeah and
this movie wisely kind of like you said
pokes fun at it
makes all those little cliches and it
shows people literally behind a control
booth who are controlling all of this
the moment that it truly gets me is the
system purge scene where all the
creatures are released as just like I
feel like that's what drew Goddard and
Joss Whedon came up with first like
they're like let's just have a thing
where the so every horror movie monster
gets unleashed how do we make that a
movie and then they just built the movie
reverse it had to be a big red button
yeah
system purge got it when classic turned
the thing and press the button exercise
to show you touch the red button Dexter
don't touch it up but indeed II know I
did II well we have two more phones we
do have two more films left two more
films let's get going let's watch his
last two yes
[Music]
going outside yes I want to get some
amazing shots of the month looks
incredible out there ooh got to show me
when you come back in indeed I will be
quick though you've got two more to film
yeah I just I just gotta get some shots
of the Stars everything I've never seen
the Stars this cool but there's like
hardly any light out there so all right
now there's like nobody for miles it's
wonderful
hi oh man I wish you guys could see this
stars out here are incredible you guys
got to take a vacation sometime in one
of these places it's just it is
all right so I just woke up and Chris
isn't back yet it's been like two hours
um he would've patient woke me up by now
I'm gonna go find him he's not up here
his camera is still here but he would
have wanted to switch cameras at some
point he's taking my photography hey
where is he
I got hurt stupid coyotes or whatever's
out there - dang we don't wanna sell
service or either funny enough I see the
owner said that there was a new year
possible down believers that can't flash
light
baby
Oh fine thing okay
please stop
Oh
you
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]